-Congratulations. Three seasons
now of "The Detour."
You play a federal agent.
Maybe not a great one?
-Yeah. She's probably not good
at her job.
-Yeah, I think that's
pretty accurate.
-Yeah, but that's kind of
status quo.
That seems appropriate
right now.
-Yeah. It's a very funny show.
Is it hard to keep it together
when you're doing scenes
like that with Jason Jones?
-Yeah. They wrote that scene,
like, the day before and then,
he and I did some, you know,
riffing, as it were.
-Yeah, sure.
-As you know,
he's a really funny guy.
-He's really funny.
-And I had to eat a lot
in that scene,
like a lot and drink a lot, too.
Not alcohol, unfortunately.
But there was one point where
he made me laugh so hard
that I actually did a spit take,
which I've never been able
to do.
-Oh, congrats.
-Yeah, thank you.
-That's really something.
-I didn't mean to.
-Sure.
-And they actually tried to use
it, but it was not appropriate.
-I think, yeah.
It would probably look a little
bit like drooling, maybe.
A spit take that happens
naturally
doesn't look the way
you picture.
-It looks pretty beautiful.
It's gorgeous. Yeah.
-So, you have --
Your daughter is one?
Just turned one.
-She's 13 months.
I know that's so annoying, but
the month makes a difference.
-I talk about it as well.
I definitely do months.
-You have to.
-I feel like
he's about to turn two,
and I feel that's when it stops.
-After that, then you're done.
-No one says 29 months.
-Some people do,
but we don't like them.
-Yeah, those people, I have
no time for them in my life.
[ Laughter ]
Are there things --
Obviously now at 13 months,
there are things she's into,
things she's not into.
What is she not into?
-She's not into, right now,
sleeping through the night.
That's not her jam.
-That's a drag.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But she's a very decisive baby.
Like, my friends joke that she's
actually not a baby.
She's a C.E.O.
She's like a tiny C.E.O.
She's a single mom.
She's working hard.
She works full time.
But we live in Harlem,
and she's like the mayor of
our four-block radius.
She walks down the street and
people are like, "Hi, Ella."
And she goes, "Hey!"
[ Laughter ]
She's literally 13 --
a year old.
But if she likes you,
she'll come up to you,
whether she knows you or not
and goes...to give you a kiss.
But then, if she doesn't like
you and a grown-up is like,
"Oh, you're so cute,"
she goes, "No-no."
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm like, "Oh, no, she's
just kidding." She's not.
-You did not grow up
in the city, right?
-I actually was born
in the city.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And then, I grew up
in New Jersey
and then came back
when I was 18.
-Because I grew up in
the suburbs, and, like,
having a New York kid is
such an interesting thing.
They are interacting with people
so much more.
Has New York as a parent
changed for you?
-Actually, yes.
It's become a friendlier,
smaller town for me
because when it was just me,
I would sort of, like,
walk down the street
with my blinders on
and not look at anyone.
And now, having this adorable
little person
who is walking around,
people always want to stop
and talk to us.
So it's a much friendlier
environment.
There's a coffee shop
we go to every morning.
And she is a regular there.
She's like the Norm of
this coffee shop.
When she walks in,
everyone says her name.
And for her birthday,
they played "Single Ladies,"
which is her favorite song.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And we put her on the table and
she danced to "Single Ladies."
All the baristas came out
from behind the counter,
and all the locals were there.
We were all dancing to
"Single Ladies."
And this one guy came in,
not a local, and started, like,
complaining, like he wanted
his coffee,
and our favorite barista,
Mariah, goes,
"Well, then, you can leave."
[ Laughter ]
-That is fantastic.
-And I was like, that's what
growing up in New York is.
-True story. I've talked about
this on the show before.
"Single Ladies,"
also my son's favorite song.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It turns out we each had
multiple iPhone videos of
our children dancing to
"Single Ladies."
-Yeah.
-So here -- They've never met.
Here's Ella and Ash dancing to
"single Ladies,"
two separate videos.
-Can't wait.
♪♪ -Oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, oh, oh,
♪♪ If you like it then you should
have put a ring on it ♪♪
♪♪ if you like it, then you
should have put a ring on it ♪♪
-Oh, my God.
-I have to say, she's half his
age and twice as good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-His footwork.
-He had, like, tango footwork
going on.
He had very intricate footwork.
-Intricate footwork.
It was like the footwork of
a very drunk man.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Start trying to get into
a fight, you know.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
But she also had
the very drunk man, like,
"I'm just gonna stand there and
like pulse my arms in the air."
-Well, she got the --
he does this every now and then,
which is very exciting.
-The first time I ever played it
for her,
I did not push Beyoncé on her.
I mean, I love Beyoncé
because I'm a human person
who lives on the planet.
-Yeah, of course. Yeah.
-But I wasn't playing it
over and over again.
The first time
when Beyoncé said,
"Put your hands up,"
my daughter went...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Five months old.
-Children -- they love
instruction.
They love instruction.
-From Beyoncé.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Only from Beyoncé.
-But he very seriously
will ask for it.
Like, he'll very earnestly go,
"Oh-oh song?"
And I think that's pretty good.
[ Audience awws ]
-Yeah.
-I want to ask.
You do something very wonderful
with Stephen Colbert.
You play the First Lady,
Melania Trump.
-I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have done it six times now.
-Yeah.
-Did you ever, obviously,
you wanted to be a performer.
You could not have imagined
many things
that have happened to you.
-Yeah. None of it.
-But could you imagine
and ever conceive of
playing the First Lady
on a late night talk show?
Are you surprised
that this has happened?
-I am shocked.
-Yeah.
-I am shocked that I would be
playing the First Lady
of the United States of America
on a talk show.
I don't think anyone could have
seen it coming, mostly her.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
But you enjoy doing it?
-I do. I do enjoy doing it.
I try not to make fun of her.
-Yeah.
-You know I try to use her as
a conduit to make fun of him.
And I kind of see her as
America.
We're all reluctantly married to
Donald Trump now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Just making the best of it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it turns out --
Yeah, like basically
the Constitution is our prenup.
We're like, how do we -- and
we're just stuck with it.
All right, great.
Your mother was a performer
as well and a voice teacher.
Is that accurate?
-Yes.
-And you convinced her to go out
and do some shows together.
-Yeah, both my parents actually
were performers.
And then when I was, like,
2 years old, they got divorced.
I'm fine.
[ Laughter ]
And my mom remarried.
My dad Sal --
we moved to New Jersey
and she never performed again.
She has an amazing voice studio
in New Jersey.
And right after
I had my daughter,
about three months after I had
my daughter,
I asked my mom if she would come
do concerts with me.
So 36 years after
being an actress,
she finally came back
on the stage with me.
-That is so cool.
-It's so cool. It's so fun.
-That's really wonderful you
guys are doing that together.
-I'm so grateful to her because
she gave up performing
to raise me in a way
that was meaningful to her,
raise me and my sister
Mary Ellen.
The fact that I get to sort of
give it back to her
is really meaningful to me
because she should have never
given it up.
-Well, that's very kind you gave
it back to her.
-Please. She gave me a life.
-There you go. That's true.
You haven't done enough!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much for being
here. Just lovely to meet you.
-Thank you for having me.